foreign
Dallas Texas hey Laura what's up
hey Dr John deloney how are you I'm all
right how are you
good um I wanted to say
um first of all I'm very sorry about
what the families in Tennessee are going
through my family and I have been
definitely praying for you guys but I'm
very thankful for your team and your
family and yourself for a show like this
because I think it's a drop in the
bucket to help us with how you said like
this world it's not the easiest so I
really appreciate everything y'all do
thank you so so much I I appreciate your
your
thinking about us and um thanks for your
call thanks for your call uh what's
going on your world
Kate I have a three and a five-year-old
both boys my husband is a teacher um I
have a 15 year old sister same parents
um my parents
um I think just got to the point where
they are doing their best but almost
have what seemed to me like have checked
out of my sister's life it the situation
has gotten um out of control where she
is leaving her school
um you know smoking has been hanging out
with the wrong crowd and my sister has a
great heart so I
um I've been trying to help my parents
in ways uh with suggestions but it's
almost like they just
don't want to upset my sister they're a
little bit scared and I suggested to
them to let her come live with me and my
family and I want to make sure I'm doing
the right thing there my parents are
planning to leave the city that they're
in to move to uh more of the
outside where like kind of like a farm
just to give my sister kind of a better
opportunities and so I offer to for her
to come live with us for a while
um and I want to make sure you know I've
always lived by like a United Family as
a strong family so I want to make sure
that I'm not causing her any harm but I
do stay home I'm going to be
homeschooling the plan is to homeschool
my sister and put her in activities to
keep her busy but like I said I'm trying
my best to not bring her harm to you
know taking away you know I don't want
to take her away from my parents at the
end of the day because that's you know
those are her parents and
um
but I do I am kind of desperate at this
point because I see how my sister's
going and I don't see the urgency in my
parents if she's leaving school that
opens up the door for her to get
trafficked
um just a whole bunch of things getting
and so yeah I'm just really nervous and
want to make sure I'm doing the right
thing for her and just wanted to see if
you had any advice or your opinion on it
yeah thanks thanks for your heart for
loving your sister
um
have you talked to her
yes I have you'll just sat down and had
just a a woman-to-woman talk
yes we have we've had a bunch of talks
and they have always been amazing
um she knows that I am not the sister to
hide lies for from my parents either if
they put her in a dangerous situation
um but she's very very open with me she
knows that she can't make decisions on
her own which my parents think a lot of
the times it's her responsibility she's
making the decision she's the one who's
buying but I always tell her look if
they're putting you in a situation that
a 15 year old like cannot decide on
herself it's not all your fault because
I mean I'm not going to give her a car
without giving her lessons how to drive
so I feel like that's kind of the
situation that she's in with
my parents so
um she you know tells me yeah that's
completely right I need someone to like
make decisions for me so I have told her
I said I think it's a good idea if maybe
you can come live with me a little while
and she also agreed and then you know
she backtracked she's like well maybe
not all summer and so I was like you
know I think it'll be healthy for you to
come live with me and have some
responsibility at my house and
um I I have the freedom to take her to
to horseback riding lessons like piano
lessons anything that keeps her busy as
well so I thought that would be good so
I
I think it I think it's a mix of both
um I think I think you're you're on the
right track with
um adults have to provide models and
pictures of what healthy relationships
look like they have to provide structure
and boundaries and when kids don't get
structure and Boundary boundaries they
go racing to see where the boundaries
end and when a kid finds no fences and
no boundaries and
um older parents who've just checked out
or younger Branch who've just checked
out and they will find boundaries
they're usually found with other kids
and that's when you're getting a huge
mess and so
um my pushback for you is this I want
you to recognize the gravity of what's
Happening Here and it may 100 be worth
it for you okay and I'm not going to
tell you right or wrong you should or
shouldn't do it but essentially what
you're doing as a 28 year old is you're
coming in and looking at your mom and
dad and saying y'all are failing at this
and the cat the cost of your failure is
the loss of my sister
I Won't Stand By and Watch that happen
um
that's different than hey why don't you
just come spin this the the summer with
big sister and here's why if she's
coming to live with you and you have
what I would call ulterior
ulterior motives I'm going to keep her
real busy I'm gonna get her in
activities you basically are inserting
yourself as
I'm gonna do a better job of parenting
her than her actual mom and dad do
if that's the thought behind it all you
gotta say those things out loud because
your sister's not stupid
correct and what you don't want to have
is her show up in two weeks in feel like
there's a bait and switch
okay oh you just brought me here because
you're gonna make me fill in the blank
you're gonna give me a bunch of chores
and a bunch I'm out of here this sucks I
thought I was just coming to hang out
with big sister because Mom and Dad are
dumb
see what I'm saying
right so it will be hey I want you to
come here I see value in you I want my
little ones to be around their um aunt
and you've got to get some structure in
your life I love you and I care about
you I'm a grown woman just 13 years down
the road from you and I see where you're
headed and I love you enough if you're
ready for a a fun summer and a summer of
accountability and change
um I love to open my house up to you you
see how one's different and she might
look at you and say absolutely not I'm
not doing that
right
um and that bring sorry go ahead no you
go ahead go ahead
that brings me Comfort because that's
that's exactly how I feel
um I don't want to be naive and think oh
I know better than my parents because
I've never had this it's easier said
than done and my parents are doing their
best regardless
um but it's true I I do want to just be
big sister and I have you know as humbly
as possible I have told my parents I
cannot stand and watch this any longer
because I have like my hands tied behind
my back with any sort of suggestion
um what do they say to you
they tell me thank you and that they
will consider you know what I say and
that they know that I love her very much
but that is easier said than done
um but it's I but I also have heard my
dad say we don't know what to do anymore
or he'll say like what do I do in this
case but it's a rhetorical question and
in my head I'm like well take the phone
away from her she shouldn't have social
media but obviously I want to respect my
my dad as well so I TR like it's very
very difficult for me to not have a
judgment towards them because this is my
one and only sister and I love her
so it's very very much
I go all in either way
okay meaning if you are
like I would sit down with my dad if I'm
you and say you have communicated
several times you don't know what to do
you've communicated several times that
that little sister's gone crazy and
she's doing this and this and we just
don't know what's next
I would like her to come live with me
for the summer and I'm going to walk her
through some things that I think would
provide some accountability and if
you're open to it after being with her
for the summer I would love to feel you
and Mom in on here's some things I think
that would be helpful I've walked this
world it's just new Everything's changed
and some dads and moms would lose their
freaking mind if their kids said that to
them
or some moms and dads May exhale and say
thank God this world just went bananas
and I don't know what to do
right right and they're a little bit of
both okay okay and I don't I don't blame
them because obviously I'm sure it's a
little hit in the ego sometimes and I
don't know best but I do try to like get
the tools that for my own kids whenever
they grow up so I just use the
suggestions from like what I'm learning
sure
I want to have as clear a picture as
possible about what happens not if but
when younger sister violates curfew when
younger sister is smoking on the back
porch or she has figured out a way to
get a hold of a phone and she whatever
your rules are going to be you and your
husband have to be lockstep and your
parents lockstep on here's what will
happen are you in a position to hold her
accountable for things and I would
suggest when she shows up
we you take her out you've heard me say
this a million times on the show with a
with a sort of helper walk through
here's what a value statement looks like
here's what a value like who are we who
are we gonna be
and you can let her know here are some
values I've made in my life and this may
be a really extraordinary time for her
for you to tell her about some
stupid guy you were with in college or
some things you said yes to that you
would like write let her know a peek
behind the curtain that she may not know
about big sister and it gives you some
um it will allow her to go oh she does
know what she's talking about right
yeah I have something in the books like
that there you go so it's not going to
be uh it's not silicious and it's not
like oh yeah look what I did too it's
not like that because I've also been
around a little bit older folks who try
to bro down
you know what I mean like use all the
cool words I've been guilty of this
before especially when I was younger of
trying to like appear cool like yeah I
know what's up and I know how to get a
hold of whatever that's not it it's hey
I've been here and here's what you don't
understand about what's coming
here's what he's got go ahead
my kids took my cool card away a long
time ago
my daughter repeatedly just tears it up
and uh hands it back to me Oh I thought
I had a few more years but no no no no
it was long gone but the The Meta word
I'm using here is Clarity very very
clear about what we're taking on okay
and if this is just summer camp at Aunt
Laura's I mean it says to Laura's house
let it be summer camp at sister Laura's
house and we're going to try to
influence positivity if this is no I'm
taking over Mom and Dad for three months
then let make sure everybody's in the
know on that
okay and be real clear with your husband
here's when she gets shipped out of here
got it here's when she goes back home
here's and let her know here's what we
can't have in this house you cannot
smoke if you're gonna be in this house
this house is social media free that
means you're gonna have to be off it too
right yep and I work yeah yes that's
true I am ready for that though awesome
and and I think and maybe even you frame
it as I'm making some Life Changes too
like I'm on social media too much I'm
off it for the summer I'm gonna look at
it once a night or whatever you can do
that in your bedroom when when she's
gone to bed or whatever the thing is
right but
um I think that the big thing here is
this is going to be harder than you
think and so let's be very very clear as
it as it happens
all right sure
okay
what does a punishment look like for oh
I know that it has to go with the you
know with what she broke but for example
I don't I'm not going to take her phone
away or her TV time because she can't
have that in myself or in my house we'd
watch movies as a family we took that
advice that y'all y'all doing y'all's
house and we we do that too so I'm
um
I'm I'm not really sure everything's
about choices but so okay everything
will be framed around choices which is
which is why your Clarity up front is so
important here's what I mean by that
if you choose to do X you're choosing to
step away from us
got it right
um I'm not don't weaponize your
relationship don't weaponize her
relationship with her nephews don't
don't weaponize her relationship with
her uncle
um because then it looks like you are
withholding love because she didn't
perform up to your standards
instead look at her and say we're
inviting you in and we're we're adding
another leg to this table and so this
house is going to function best when
you're here
okay and you're a part of it
um I want you to have a um an hour in
the morning with the boys I'll pay you
and I'm gonna hire you for some of this
stuff this summer
um so you can have the experience of
having a job too right
um and maybe it's maybe it's sister
Laura's Boot Camp or summer whatever you
however you want to frame it but frame
it in a positive yet this is not going
to be easy right and I think kids today
are craving challenges
they're desperate for adults to look at
them and say whoa whoa you can do so
much more right it's it's just providing
like you said the scaffolding to that so
the whole thing didn't fall over when
they make mistakes but it's going to be
her if you if you if you you can't this
is a house where we don't curse in front
of the kids
if you curse in front of the kids you're
choosing to not be in the room with
those kids please don't make that choice
this house works so much better when
you're here and then she does it which
she will
then you have to hold that line because
your mom and dad don't hold that line
and she's gonna see if you're telling
the truth or not yes right right so
everything is about choices she's making
if she chooses to go home because she
finds some dude to give her alcohol she
chooses to go home because she finds
somebody to buy her smokes and what like
that's a choice she makes
and it's let her know this breaks my
heart because I wanted you here I want
you here and you're choosing to leave
perfect that makes complete sense
I'm very excited
I love her very
much let me know how it goes
love to call me anytime throughout the
summer not if but when it gets sideways
in in bananas
um but I think
as much honesty and openness as possible
and keep a tiny little
um space in your heart for this thing
whole thing to go south
yes sister to say I hate you you're dumb
remember she's a child right yep yep and
your parents to say how dare you I I
wiped your butt I watched your mom give
birth to you expect all that crap too
correct totally fine with me I don't
even care so okay as yeah I know as you
know I'm gonna be my very best and do it
as loving as possible and I'm not going
to blame anyone for how they react not
by business how someone else reacts but
I am going to do my best I love that uh
clear as kind clear as kind clear as
kind and Laura thank you for loving her
and thank you for loving your parents
and
um
no parent no parent wants their kids to
give them advice
it's the brave parents it I'll just be
honest my mom called me this morning and
said hey I'm working through an issue
what do you think there's there's
something really profound when a parent
goes oh great one of my kids is an
expert in this thing or they know this
thing I'll call them that's awesome many
parents don't have the courage or the
strength to get there
um moms and dads if you're over your
head and you've got a great child like
Laura Reach Out reach out and say hey
can you help
um we're at our Wit's End here and we
need we need some support
um but for those of you you kids who are
just like Mom and Dad are making stupid
decisions sometimes they have more
wisdom than you sometimes it's it's a
different conversation and sometimes you
just gotta be prepared for them to say I
would rather take I would rather take
wisdom from uh raccoons backside
raccoon's butthole then from from you I
I don't know where raccoon's butthole
came from I just screwed up this whole
call sorry guys but Laura you know what
you know what I'm talking about